so ken according this article at yahoo
finance
the federal reserve bank of new york
reported thursday that the
covet 19 pandemic had led to pay downs
of
household debt in the second quarter of
2020
leading to the first quarter over
quarter decline
since 2014. the new york fed's consumer
debt panel
our consumer credit panel uh which uses
national data
from equifax shows that total household
debt fell by 34 billion
to 14.27 trillion as of june 30.
the most notable decline in consumer
debt came from credit card spending
where balances fell 76 billion in the
second quarter
the steepest decline in the history of
the new york fed's data
auto and student loan balances were
roughly flat
the data shows of show signs of caution
over consumer spending well no kidding
mortgage balances however continued to
rise and added 63 billion so basically
we got student loans flat
we got um and to the extent that this
particular
uh region of the fed is indicative of
everything else we don't know about that
for sure but
it makes sense it makes sense so credit
card debt's down
uh student loan debt's flat mortgages
are up because we were buying houses
still
and um auto loans are basically flat
our auto debt is flat so what amounts to
is that people
weren't going to restaurants and they
weren't traveling
and they weren't using their credit
cards and they paid them down because
they were scared
that's right some good news though in
this in june we saw consumer spending
rise by 5.6 so that speaks to some
confidence
and the delinquency rates on mortgages
that's right so it it this is a great
article to share because
you know you hear all the doom and gloom
and if you're watching news
or you're reading news a lot of
clickbait out there a lot of stories
designed to get your head to turn uh
these are real economic numbers and that
would at least suggest
that uh better days are ahead you and i
have believed that all the ramsey
personalities we've said that our
messages of hope are saying that this is
a storm
storms pass there's some good news here
and uh there is there's hope uh that
some people are saying you know what
never again and uh and that's what we're
seeing and i'm encouraged i think
as time moves on uh we're gonna see
business owners start to help beat the
drum a little bit to say you know what
if we're going to survive if we're going
to thrive we're going to have to figure
out how to work and people want to work
and so i'm still in a place of optimism
even though the news isn't always
positive i'm optimistic
yeah the um i think one of the things
that's
uh negative not not
out of this article but overall is um
the uh the same place in your brain the
same chemical reaction in your brain
that causes someone to become addicted
to pornography
causes them to become addicted to fear
and some of these news channels have
basically been putting out fear porn
for about four months now and they've
gotten record ratings off of it it's
working for them
and uh they found a new story
occasionally to move on from it but they
go right back to fear porn
because it's working for them and some
of you have watched the news so much
that you've become addicted to fear
and you spend your whole life just
trembling uh
and you what happens when the you do
that is you lose your critical thinking
skills
so you no longer have the ability to
look at
mask data or social distancing data
or death rates with a clear mind
uh you know you no longer can look at
the inconsistencies in the testing
processes
with a clear mind and come to a
reasonable
common sense conclusion instead
your octaves go up because your throat
is tight
and you screech at someone in the
grocery store
yeah because you're addicted to fear
you've been you've gotten hooked on fear
porn
and uh so nothing that no one can reason
with you
because you've lost your freaking mind
yeah those people are seeing a threat
everywhere
they're seeing a threat everywhere you
know it's interesting you talk about the
the part of the brain
you can look this up uh google lizard
brain and that's become the kind of
the the common man description of that
part of our brain but it really does
protect us the brain is designed to
protect us and it's called fight or
flight
and so what dave's talking about folks
is is absolutely backed up from
neuroscience
that when we get so focused on fear
we have our brain will put us into one
or two places and we get to choose most
people dave as you're saying are
choosing flight i'm afraid i'm going to
contract everything in my life i'm not
going to go anywhere i'm not going to do
anything i'm going to freak out
and i'm going to get in this bunker and
i'm going to be mad at anybody who
doesn't do what i do
that's the issue or what if we choose
the fight mechanism say you know what
look
this is out of our control a lot of this
is out of our control but what can i
control well i can control what i focus
on
i can find good stories that aren't just
uh kumbaya cotton candy i'm talking
some of the data we've given you here uh
the jobs numbers new job numbers came
out today
less job unemployment than they
predicted i look at that and i go
that's optimistic you know we've got not
exactly a check mark
it's not it didn't just bounce back it
didn't bounce back and the reason it
didn't was we've continued with
some of the draconian policies that's
right but we also got small business men
and women that are fighting
to save their business fighting to save
your job
we've got entrepreneurs that are
fighting to come up with
new business models and new consumer
products
that are coming out of these times the
point is we've got to choose to say
i'm not going to let this circumstance a
pandemic and everybody else's reaction
to it
color my perspective and thus my actions
i think
it's well said we've got to be careful
what we consume yeah
fear of porn if you consume fear all the
time that's all you see is an attack
around every corner yeah
and you you become subject to it you're
now absolutely
and you can see people's eyes oh yeah
they're skulking around
you know oh where's the boogeyman all
the time as opposed to going look this
is a tough time
america's been through tough times
before other countries been through
tough times
and what have we seen the human spirit
if it decides
to fight and to and to say all right
we're going to overcome this and adapt
then good things can happen and i i am i
am very optimistic i just
trust business people man if we can just
to get the government out of business
uh i feel real good about you the people
i do
well because you know this idea that
somehow business people are
out to harm their employees it's
absolutely astonishing
garbage that's asinine yeah they can't
do that on purpose we spend so much
money
acquiring team members right the amount
of money i spend recruiting and getting
people here
and then turn around kill them right
that would just that's asinine well
you've said 100 times you can't can't
get to the vision that we have for
ramsay solutions as it continues to
evolve and grow without people
yeah so we turned off our hiring for 60
days because we were conserving cash to
make sure we were going to turn the
corner and survive
we've uh you know we've stabilized our
revenues now we've pivoted and pivoted
until i'm sick of the word
and um and so we're back in full higher
mode
now and uh we'll hire 200 people by the
end of the year probably
uh and and so you know can you i was
talking with a guy last night in
business and
can you imagine being in the plexiglass
business right now
oh my goodness they can't they can't
hire it
you can't keep it no it's like
everywhere everybody's got a piece of
glass up somewhere
and you know every cash register
suddenly has this it is absolutely like
being in the mass production business
how about how about all those toilet
paper uh executives right now and the
and the paper towel people they are
living good right now after all the
collective freak out
in america three months ago you couldn't
find toilet paper
if you tried you couldn't find it the
great toilet paper shortage of the
spring of 2020.
well i mean it's what it's it's it's
crazy i mean there's opportunity
everywhere
uh gosh we just have to uh
we have to infect people i know you're
going to get on that word but i chose it
on purpose
we've got a fear of fear is more
contagious
that's virus but we have got to infect
people with some optimism to say you
know virus is highly contagious by the
way oh i know
but the fear is more fear is way more
and by the way
i'm going to say this the fear and the
fallout
of this virus and the draconian
leadership measures
will have harmed more people than the
actual virus when this is all said
definitely all kinds of all kinds of
data already showing that
all kinds of data already showing that
it's uh
the good news is they didn't run up
their debt credit cards that's the data
that's good we still got work to do
though
there's still 76 billion in just credit
cards me and you were gonna be okay me
and jenny craig got a lot of work to do